[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
من قوات حفظ السلام التابعه للامم المتحده
وذلك في خطوه تنجرت بالتنسيق مع حزب الله
وقال المصدران الامنيين انه يشتبه بان
الرجل اطلق عيره ناريه على مركبه تابعه
لقوه الامم المتحده المؤقته في لبنان
اليونيفيل اثناء تحركها في الجنوب يوم
الخامس عشر من ديسمبر وانكر حزب الله
رسميا تورطه في الامر ووصفه بانه واقعه
غير متعمده بين سكان البلده وليونفل فقط
وتابع من بيروت مع جورج عقوري الباحث
السياسي ومن بيروت ايضا بنجم الكاتب
السياسي مرحبا بكما معنا ابدا معك سيد
جورج هل تسليم حزب الله همم للمتهم بقتل
الجندي الايرلندي في اليونيفيل هو
استراتيجيه مقربه جديده للحزب للتعاطي مع
اليونيفيل مع المجتمع الدولي ام هي يعني
بناء على توجيهات من ايران في سبيل ربما
همم تخفيف الضغط عن ايران في هذه المرحله
طبط اوقاتك اولا لا اتصور ان الامر بناءا
على توجيهات من ايران لتخفيف الضغط عليها
لان الحادثه هي حادثه موضعيه من حيث حجمها
اي ليست فتح جبهه مع اسرائيل لنقول ان
الامر يرتبط بايران بالمباشر انما هي
عمليه موضعيه او الرساله
تحمل رساله مشفره همم قام بها همم ان كان
حزب الله او قامت بها بيعه حزب الله ونحن
نعلم جيدا عن في هذه القرى هناك مجموعات
امنيه لحزب الله موجوده وان الامر ليس
بهذه السهوله وليس بالبساطه ان يتم اطلاق
نيران على مركبه همم للقوات المساله وان
يتم اصابه اربعه داخل هذه المركبه فالامر
ليس يعني المساله ليست مساله هو يطلقون
النار ابتهاجا
المساله مساله مطلق نار محترف
ما هي هذه الرسائل المشفره اذا لم تكن
كذلك
يعني هناك احتمالات عده قد تكون من بينها
رساله
هي اتت متاخره شهرين من بعد موقف امين عام
حزب الله في ايرون الماضي بعد تحديد مهام
قوات ليون فل
والالتباس الذي جرى هل يمكنها التحرك داخل
ال 17 01 بمفردها ام برفقه الجيش يمكن ان
تكون ايضا رساله الى
الدعوه التي اطلقت من قبل البتريارك
الماروني الى تدوين او عقد مؤتمر دولي من
اجل لبنان يمكن ان تكون ايضا رساله عن
الحزب ما زال الممسك الاول والاخير بالامن
في الجنوب وفي مناطق اخرى لذا اا الرساله
مشفره لكن هذه الرساله من مصلحه الحزب ان
تكون مضبوطه ومحدوده لانه همم الحزب اخذ
قرارا من خلال ترسيم همم الترسيم الحدود
تم الترسيم البحري كان هناك اعتراف من قبل
الحزب بشكل مباشر او غير مباشره بضروره
تهدئه وضبط الامن همم في الجنوب اللبناني
بعد ما كنا شاهدنا في العام 2006 ضبط
الامن البريه نحن مع ترسيم نشهد وضبط امن
او تحولت سلاح الحزب الى ما يشبه حراسه
بشكل غير مباشره لان منصات التي سوف
تستخرج الغاز ولا يمكن يعني وليس من توقع
حوادث امنيه كبيره تؤدي الى خربطه المشهد
للاستقرار في الجنوب اللبناني نعم استاذ
مشاري بن نجم همم اجدد ترحيب بك معنا كما
تفضل الاستاذ جورج يعني قبل ذلك كان مساله
التعاون في موضوع
اتفاق استخراج الغاز الان حزب الله همم
يتعاون كذلك في تسليم المتهم بقتل الجندي
ايرلندي همم هل هو تغيير لي المسار من قبل
حزب الله يمكن ان نتسائل اما هو يبقى
دائما في اطار كما قال ضيفي انه توجيه
الرسائل مشفره بطريقه مضبوطه
مساء الخير لكم وللزميل جورج في الحقيقه
ان حزب الله
معني اولا هو لديه مقاربه بريغماتيه يعني
لديه ربما تمسك بثواب استراتيجيه ولكن
لديه كما ايران بريغماتيه في التكتيكات
السياسيه ثانيا لا مصلحه لحزب الله بتصعيد
الوضع اكثر مما هو الواقع الان في جنوب
لبنان على اثر الحادثه التي حصلت والتي
ادت الى مقتل الجندي الايرلندي لان نتيجه
الترسيم المنطقه الاقتصاديه وتداعياتها
همم السياسيه همم تفرض نوعا من الاستقرار
السياسي والامني في جنوب لبنان طويل الامل
بغض النظر عن التوترات التي ربما ستبقى
بين بين اسرائيل وبين الدوله اللبنانيه
وبين همم حزب الله يعني التوترات قائمه
لكن عدم تصعيد الوضع الى حرب كبيره او الى
توتر امني كبير هو الثابت منذ الان وحتى
همم بعيد نتيجه لهذا الاتفاق بالتالي هذا
يسري ايضا على التوتر ب في العلاقه بين
حزب الله وقوات اليونيفيل وهذا التوتر ليس
جديدا فقد حصلت حوادث كثيره في السابق بين
الاهالي الذين المؤيدين لحزب الله بطبيعه
الحال وهمم وقوات اليونيفيل ودورياتها في
مناطق في المناطق وفي القرى اذا كان هناك
من رساله لحزب الله باتجاه القوات الدوليه
فهي رساله وصلت واذا لم تكن رساله وكانت
حادثه ربما غير مقصود غير واضحه المعالم
حتى الان فهي الان في عهده الجيش اللبناني
وفي وفي عوده مخابرات الجيش كطرف موثوق به
سواء من القوات الدوليه وسواء من من حزب
الله للاضاءه هذا الامر لكن في المجمل وفي
البعد السياسي لهذا الموضوع هناك وضع
ضوابط لعدم انزلاق الوضع الى اي وقت ولا
ننسى ان الواقع السياسي في لبنان بما
يشهده من تصفيات همم او مح ثلاثه احداث
خارق لانتخاب رئيس الجمهوريه
والتقاطعات الاقليميه والدوليه ترخي
بذلالها على الواقع السياسي اللبناني
وتفرد نوعا من عدم الانزلاق الى اي توتر
يضر بمصلحه كل الاطراف المعنيه بالوضع في
الجنوب همم استاذ جورج كيف تعلق حزب الله
يتعامل ببرجماتيه بالنظر الى حساسيه الوضع
الان في لبنان وكذلك في الاقليم وفي
الخارج كذالك
وشاطره الراي ان حزب الله الزميل من
الشارع
من مصالحه وعمليه عن تسليم همم متهم
باطلاق نيران اليوم على قوات اليونيفيل
همم ربما لن يكون ذات جدوى ان احنا نتذكر
حادثه النقيب الطيار في الجيش اللبناني
سامر حنا الذي تم اا تم قتله من قبل
المجموعه من حزب الله في ثلاث سجود في
العام 2008 تم تسليم احدهم وقيل انه هو من
اطلق النيران همم وبعد فتره وقبل انتهاء
المحاكمه اخرجه بكفاله ولم يعد يحضر رجاله
سات ثم قيل انه قتل في سوريا ثم قيل انه
قتل في جنود ارسال وتبين في تحقيقات انه
لديه عطب جسدي لا يمكنه القيام باطلاق
نيران على الشهيد سامحنا لذا يعني قد يكون
وجدوا اي شخص يكون كبش محرقه ديمه خصوصا
في ظل تسريبات التي تقول ان ان الشاب الذي
اطلق نيران هو حداد وليس منتصب لحزب الله
بالمناصر لحزب الله ان طبيعه العمليه يجمع
لا ننسى ان السياره كانت مصفحه وتم كسر
هذه السياره وتم اصابه اربعه لعناصر اربعه
في داخلها يعني هذه كلها مؤشرات تدل ان
الامر ليس بهذه البساطه وبهذه السهوله
وانها ليس فقط غضب الاهالي كما اعتدنا على
هذه المشهديه نعم طيب هل استاذ مش انا
بالنجم هل ايضا من باب البراغماتيه انه
عدم التصعيد انه حزب الله يريد الامور
مضبوطه لانه همم وضع اللبنانيين لا يحتمل
اي تصعيد او اي مواجهه وبالتالي همم
لبنانيون سينقلبون بشكل كبير اذا ما همم
تدهور الوضع في لبنان اكثر
في الحقيقه لا احد ينكر التوتر بين حزب
الله والقوات اليونيفيل كما قلت لك على
مدى اعوام سابقه لكن ان ينطلق حزب الله
الى مواجهه مع القوات الدوليه التي تنتشر
بكثافه في جنوب لبنان مع ما يرتبه ذلك من
تداعيات على وضعياته الامنيه والسياسيه
والانزلاق الى مواجهات غير محسوبه فلا
اعتقد ان حزب الله يريد يريد هذا الموضوع
انا اعتقد اي اا بين متزوجين هواجس او
مخاوف او همم علاقه متوتره بين حزب الله
وقوات اليونيفيل هذه لديه اسبابها التي
ربما لا نعلمها ولا يعلنها همم حزب الله
يعني هناك من يقول مثلا انه همم هناك تخوف
من علاقه بعض عناصر اليونيفيل الذين
يدخلون الى اسرائيل هناك مثلا همم هواجس
او خوف من اجتياز قوات اليونيفيل ل- اا
مناطق سير دورياتها
واحيانا كثيره كانت تحصل
اي يسمى بيئه حزب الله نظرا ال- لانهم
كانوا يقومون نعم بتصوير مناطق يعتبرها
حزب الله انها تضر بانه لكن هذا لا يعني
ان احدا يريد مواجهه مفتوحه مع المستعد
الدولي لن انسى ان وصلت الفكره الاستاذ
ميشيل ولكن حزب الله يريد ان تبقي الامور
مضبوطه في هذه المرحله مش الذي نجم الكاتب
السياسي من بيروت شكرا جزيلا لك وجورج
عقوري الباحث السياسي كذلك من بيروت شكرا
جزيلا لك مشاهدينا الكلام شكرا لكم انتم
على كرم المشاهده الى اللقاء